after having combated viruses my whole
professional life
virus got me and this was kovit 19.
there's quite a difference from studying
a virus from combating it from the
outside
and from having it in every single cell
in your body
and it makes me now a double expert an
expert from the outside an expert
from the inside
viruses don't know borders viruses don't
know
classes sex and whatever we must be
realistic first of all this is only the
beginning
of this pandemic the choice is very
clear to me
either we will have a vaccine and people
will be vaccinated and accepted or
we don't take a vaccine and we don't
have a vaccine and
we will have to be continuously in this
crazy situation
of lockdowns and we know for sure now
that with our
natural immunity we can get rid of the
virus
look at me otherwise i wouldn't be here
and that means that
a vaccine is possible
within a year we will have probably
between five and ten
different vaccines we cannot take any
shortcuts
first of all to demonstrate that it
works it protects
but secondly such a vaccine as other
vaccines has to be absolutely safe
and that again has to be tested
on many thousands of people and we need
to make sure
that people feel comfortable with it
that they say this this is going to save
my life
[Music]
let's be clear the only way out of this
pandemic
is a vaccine